what's up party people
welcome to Amish trailer commentaries
for our first career retrospective of
Wes Anderson catch the full trailer over
on screen junkies and come back here
watch this video stick around the end
for deleted scenes which I think we have
C no no there's Joe start hello there's
Dan Merle watch this trailer with me
yes let's oh very very Sanders thank you
every rustle very nicely symmetrical we
are yeah can we get perfectly
symmetrical
let's try genius so he tried something
different for this one he's got a
adorable looking movie coming out Isle
of Dogs that I can't wait to see so we
figured like he doesn't have one movie
that so much stands out above the others
although you know I have my favorites I
think we all do but they're all kind of
like different variations on the same
film if you will
ish it's a damn good film dan you did
the moat the Yeomans work for this one
you watched every single and I just
filled in the blanks for me for the ones
I hadn't seen but you've been watched
every single Wes Anderson I watched all
of them all of the Anderson's yeah looks
for themes patterns repetition mm-hmm
there were things that I noticed that I
had not noticed before some things that
I thought would be there that we're not
there and I know like most of what you
notice is all in the trailer but like
generally a positive experience you're
watching all those already that's one of
the easier honest Joe it's
time-consuming but it's also like hey
watch eight movies that are varying
degrees of good yeah I would wedgie
hasn't made a bad movie there's some
that I start dealing as a little for me
yeah but it was a terrible it's just
coming but there's some great ones I
love grand Budapest Royal Tenenbaums
that's my favorite I love Rushmore
I'd never seen fantastic mr. Fox I
enjoyed that one quite a bit moonrise
kingdom I think is the most Wes Anderson
ii of the wes anderson movies yeah
darling is that was okay and then bottle
rocket is very interesting proto wes
anderson and
life aquatic again is quirky but I
connect more with the Royal Tenenbaums
in grand Budapest I'm just realizing
that I don't fall asleep during movies
often but I fell asleep during
Darjeeling twice once at this office and
then also during moonrise kingdom not
that they're boring they're just
soothing I find very just like if you
need white noise to sleep literal white
noise should have been a title white
noise but yeah I mean that I don't mean
that as an insult they're just like it's
like you're in that very I don't know
placid world where like no one's
emotions ever get too hot or too cold
the music's like twee and and plinky
behind them and everything looks cute
yeah they're all very soothing colors
like strange outbursts of horrific
violence but like no one really reacts
too strongly to it anyways no no one
reacts too strongly to anything these
films yeah yeah Joe laughs aquatic my
favorite was anderson film me too yeah
yeah I feel like Bill Murray challenged
him a little bit that's what that movie
feels like it's no Murray pushing him
out of his comfort zone a little okay it
feels right in his comfort zone to me
like that's that's just peak peak Wes
everything in that movie purest
distillation of yeah III think that left
quarks my favorite probably just as I've
seen it the most but I think the best
thing bad I think he's getting better
I think grand Budapest was his best work
and I love guys look great so I think
that he's someone who like can still
push himself a little bit or at least
just get better and better at the thing
he does yeah he always seems to have
like a film like when you need it like I
know like with Dan like I I pretty sure
there was a semester of college where I
watched Royal Tenenbaums every day
probably just because I was like this
man speaks to me I get it
yeah well trailer for mr. Wes Anderson
tell us and come into what other career
filmmakers career you'd like us to do
one X may be limited filmography yeah
please
before you see the whimsical new
animated feature before you see the
whimsical nip before you see the
whimsical new Empire
you know what the epic was just isn't
the right fit for Wes Anderson get
anyone here do a good Alec Baldwin hello
close enough take it away Baldy buzz
buzz so this was a discussion we had
very early on about the voice hmm and if
we should you know we wanted to make it
very tenant bowel mm-hmm yeah tendon
bombing which to John's credit we asked
him like can you do a bald when he's
like it's not really my you know in my
my zone so he kind of gauged his
blessing for us to cast the net outwards
and we ended up finding a great great
Alec Baldwin we have an excellent Alec
Baldwin yeah just on deck yeah in the
office randomly anyway wasn't cast
because he was in the office but they
just literally happened to be working in
our office this when we were recording
we need to do a video of him just
reading Alec Baldwin's mean tweets
[Laughter]
before you see the whimsical new
animated feature from your baristas
favorite director revisit all his
meticulously crafted awkward family
fables that make you kinda happy kinda
sad and kinda unsure when you're
supposed to laugh or not
[Music]
where are they laughing Wes Anderson
movie
I mean film every Wes Anderson film
sally forth and Tallyho with director
Wes Anderson whose style is so specific
he's basically his own genre featuring
more symmetrical shots than you can
shake an art department at more
nostalgia than you can cram into a
quirky indoor tent and more whimsy than
a lovestruck Cub Scout dancing in his
underwear to a lakeside record player
honestly after eight movies I'm not sure
if I made that shot up or not it is he
quest ensign I gave Wes Anderson
protagonists he's definitely not a woman
but an emotionally stunted man suffering
from a vague bout of on Yui how was that
supposed to make us feel watch him deal
with a strained parental relationship
your mother's asked me to leave why
didn't you come sooner like we're all
being lulled to sleep just watch the
system right and maybe an affair you've
made a comment I think he's on to us of
course he is but with the help of a
brown subordinate slash love interest a
Wardrobe full of dapper menswear and a
classic slow-motion walk he'll end up
happy I think it's sort of hard to tell
but that's what makes it artistic us
that watching them all in fairly quick
succession over about a week or so they
seem very therapeutic in the sense of
like you can tell that he's going
through some stuff or yeah this is
outlet to not go through stuff but it's
it's all all all parent issues
everyone has parent issues they're
usually dead or gone absent always some
kind of dysfunction
there there is a there is a surprising
theme of like helpful service employees
elevator operators cleaning people's
assistants taxi drivers
trained stewardesses like people that
are like in positions of survey
servitude that are helpful to their lead
characters on their quest I'm really
curious how what how he grew up what his
family life is like this is Wes Anderson
have some siblings that like Beck Beck
yes
Beck buy it yeah what was the what do
you think his Jaguar shark was in real
life that ate his friend what was that
about
yeah good question like tommy was so
definitely had a Lisa yeah what was was
Jaguar yeah his estranged stepsister
broke his zoetrope and and then his dead
dad left him on a funicular okay yeah
it's been to get over it ever since
yeah that's the only way a rickshaw I
know is this this this reverence for
very specific he has like a reverence
for like craftsmanship
typed things handwritten yes things
paint paintings he like hand painted and
hand drawn things it's yeah because I
was we watching a bunch of the movies
and I got to Darjeeling and it he pulls
out an iPod that was like Dylan go
electric yeah yeah but a old cars old
tiny uniforms you know the the Tenenbaum
house is full of books and old board
game it's like this very kind of a
reverence for the non digital for the
the tactile it's very straight again and
of course that's become a huge hipster
trope but he was he's been doing it for
so long
yeah like since Rushmore at least if not
bottle rocket that like he he's the UH
hipster he's the these patients here
tabula rasa rosetta stone
yeah the resistive modern hipster isn't
yeah
facial hair and just the idea of putting
on a stage play a meticulously
hand-crafted movies play of a movie it's
just I don't it's I don't know what
exactly is it work there it's very inch
just want to get into his brain and be
like why are you why are you you again
yeah I really think we need to dig into
his his past
yeah yeah yeah very interesting anyways
intriguing carry on revisit eight films
as meticulously crafted as the dollhouse
sets they probably feature including a
tale of two disaffected friends the
cleaning woman that one of them loves
and a meticulously planned robbery that
goes wrong a tale of this disaffected
student his disaffected older friend the
teacher both of them love and a
meticulously planned revenge plot that
goes wrong a tale of this disaffected
family the sister that one of them loves
his friend takes lightly plan sixteen
minutes goes wrong a tale of this
disaffected oceanographer the reporter
both he and his son love and a
meticulously planned documentary that
goes wrong a tale of these disaffected
brothers the trains do it is one of them
loves and a meticulously planned trip
through India that goes wrong a tale of
his disaffected Fox the wife he loves
and a meticulously planned different
robbery that goes long a tale of these
disaffected kids who are in love with
each other and a meticulously planned
escape that or an end of fast for a bank
to measure the dead old one he locks and
the meticulously planned heist that goes
wrong it sounds repetitive but trust me
they're just the most charming little
things thanks so before you see the
adorable looking Isle of Dogs I leave as
it the director doesn't only near
scribed as Wes Anderson who's influenced
an entire generation of indie filmmakers
and an even larger generation of pale
hipsters who hate their parents you just
use accepted me - I was born in the
wrong decade starring overhead shots of
objects before we get to play deposit
this was obviously very long run of
things but I think one thing that I
noticed as I was writing or not writing
but as I was watching is you know I was
writing down things that I noticed
repetition and then I noticed that they
started as
you went on they started to be they
started to combine so that was kind of
the things like alright let's start with
the things but you know again it's like
a lot of people rift on the West
Anderson tropes my favorite is the
midnight cautery of sinister intruders
listen oh so let people kind of rip down
the tropes it's like what's our take on
it and it seemed like well let's riff on
the kind of mix the mix and match of all
things of just like actor tropes shots
and you know the character beats it's
very layered he's layering tropes on
tropes on TRO he is it's a trope
turducken yeah let's see which ones we
found
starring overhead shots of objects stage
plays funerals facial wounds zooms
[Music]
never - TJ - good job kind of put adjust
together right in shots of typewritten
letters with pass to see a film school
guy or is he like self-taught Wes
Anderson yeah I would imagine he's
probably old-school characters
explaining elaborate plans this is a big
chart very
we'll start with Bacchus walk at house
number one it's 25 an early legged pose
granite masonry I like to pitch camp
here about 1,600 characters running away
suddenly
[Music]
it's my favorite the future of font
whimsical names Bob Daimler Bob painful
for every Apple rose made cross
Applejack did I miss a little gene face
watches you tried five Kara the first
with dead parents my mother that Sam's
parents passed away a number of years
ago you should have been a dead Channel
my father died at seven-and-a-half my
father was murdered willem dafoe dead
animals this was disturbing hmm he loves
killing animals which is the sign of a
serial killer
oh it's one of the tell-tale signs of a
serial killer oh my god he would make a
great serial he would make the most but
he would be the Dexter yeah yeah this
guy would erase every track frame it so
it looks like someone else entirely he'd
be that I'll tell you right now his name
would be the dollhouse killer yes
because he would put all of the bodies
and intricate tableaus based on 18th
century novels but this is one
disturbing thing that I noticed was he
loves to kind of needlessly and in a way
that has no real impact on the plot kill
animals mmm
which is which is string no very
casually mention it like he killed a
bird when he was 8 or willem dafoe just
throws a cat out the window the dog gets
run over and Royal Tenenbaums there's a
dog and moonrise kingdom that just gets
shot with an arrow and just like the
dogs dead ok moving on it's very
disturbing I think that hit just his
threshold for getting like an emotional
response out of him is so high that like
you need to do something extreme for him
to feel I guess or is he just trying to
impose order on a an unstructured world
that deserves to be made clean oh god
the signs are all there yeah the one
font the uniforms you had all the clues
police yeah they were typewritten on
this crafted piece of paper from the
from my childhood spiral notebook yeah
Nords the dollhouse killer yes oh boy
okay
let's keep going we just ruined it and
animals
Willem Dafoe playing a dead animal
anjelica huston old timey telephones
anjelica huston on an old timey
telephone foreigners classic rock songs
[Music]
oil paintings a foreigner playing a
classic rock song in front of an oil
painting characters reading books
uniforms graveyards a character reading
a book wearing a uniform in a graveyard
Jason Schwartzman smoking in moving
vehicles Jason Schwartzman smoking
outside a moving vehicle a Wilson
brother strange sibling relationships
exotic animals a Wilson brother and his
estranged sibling smoking with an exotic
animal and Norton reel-to-reel tape
recorders Ed Norton dictating into a
reel-to-reel tape recorder while smoking
and wearing a uniform
Bill Murray tiny motorcycles profile
shots and Bill Murray on a tiny
motorcycle episode file shot know right
it's very strange
every Wes Anderson movie you know we
gave him crap for repeating himself but
the last thing anyone wants is a
desaturated shaky-cam CGI fest out of
him just a movie about the drama club at
Hogwarts yeah it's pretty much Rushmore
just add magic what have you done yeah
yeah yeah I I saved transfiguration yeah
I kind of don't want him to change I
want him to stay in his precious little
bubble it's an adorable little bubble
it's handcrafted hand knit crocheted
bubble yeah absolutely I want to see I
want to make a movie entirely out of
matchsticks that's his next project old
sets are just matchsticks yeah I'd watch
that yeah I want him to make an entire
movie out of mosaics just tiles yeah
just perfectly symmetrical tiles
I'm into that too he's hollywood's most
special little boy yes he's just
delightful they're just the most darling
little things as may be I say this a lot
but that's currently my favorite line
you've ever read just the most this arc
is like you just know they're cute cute
weird dark they're movies that I just
want to pat on the head
sort of condescendingly but also like
just realize remember those thumb war
movies movies very symmetrical thumbs
old Bowie songs all right yeah Wes
Anderson and Spike Jones are locked in a
cage who comes out alive for you dude
he's a murderer
okay versus film but oh film versus film
oh I thought you meant actual fighting
that's definitely what's Anderson
there's a lot of rage bottled up there
in that Thuy suit that's a really good
movie fight questions by Jones versus
Wes Anderson who's Hollywood specialist
boy boy yeah it is it has ruined me a
little bit for future Wes Anderson films
because I already in the trailer for I
love dogs I know just like - she was in
a reel to reel it looked like there
wasn't one characters speaking into a
reel-to-reel tape recorder
I will now not be able to watch or
what's Anderson movie and not think
about like oh yeah do you think one of
the dogs not just gonna be smoking yeah
I don't know can you can a dog smoke in
a pg-13 they just can't look up you know
what Wes Anderson / Jones yeah is it
weird that even though we've like laid
out everything he does it still seems
like Spike Jones is trying harder than
Wes Anderson see I feel like it would be
Spike Jones cuz Spike Jones spent way
too much time around skateboarders to
not know how to handle himself like oh
sorry yes so I'm going back to the
actual fight have you seen how
skateboarders treat each other like to
spend that much time around skate boy
yes I say Spike Jones wins in the fight
but without their skateboard there
they're generally helpless you know they
use that as a club no I just mean
generally just the just just the breaks
to his bones are gonna be so symmetrical
like perfect I could just see ya West
knowing like Aikido or something we're
like you use their own momentum against
them or he like just does a nerve pinch
like at the exact precise right spot and
then he just crumbles I just killed you
you have 14 seconds to live I would I
want him to remake I want him to remake
Dexter oh okay and just re myself yeah
starring himself or just Owen Wilson uh
to have a deleted scene safety let's
play let's play them I kind of put this
plastic down just more stories starring
characters getting into a scuffle it's
not exclusive to him but he does do that
alone and these are skulls yeah doesn't
fight those two scuffles people talking
into two-way radios
waving
[Music]
yeah so in Wilson's
twee stir yeah there we go is just kind
of few things for time yeah mostly all
up there yeah it's not much else to say
about Wes Anderson no he is who we
thought he was horrible murderer no I
just discovered that I'm not saying he
is a psychopath I'm saying that the dead
animal thing exhibits all the greats yes
yes the meticulous nature the the dead
animal thing I'm just saying look out
well you heard of here first is wes
anderson serial killer or good direct of
our hearts of our hearts yes we hope you
enjoyed that one sorry didn't have too
much to say about it just lulls me to
sleep I'm sorry I just want to take a
nap so chill next week though might be
the last oh this is right oh you ever do
yeah this is the opposite of chill yeah
yeah there was no chill for next week's
trailer no joke no chill have zero zero
chill might be time for honest trailers
to end after that it's not gonna go the
way you think it will no but it will and
we'll see you next week bye guys
you